when you talk to jordan peterson
recently and people should
listen to that conversation it was a
fascinating one
i think um he he
he almost got emotional on the
discussion about
universities and your experience with
colombia
because he like myself for perhaps
different reasons
have a hope for our academic
institutions
some of the most incredible people some
of the most incredible
engineering and idea development
innovations happens in universities and
so
we both deeply care about them um
is there something so the reason he got
emotional the reason he was kind of hurt
is
the the the fact that you did not
you were not deeply inspired by your
experience
deeply it made me dumber it made
me scared it made me terrified
that i had to censor myself in america
like
like are you seriously telling me that
you don't ever censor yourself and when
you talk
do you can you truly say whatever you
want about race
about anything gender we all censor
ourselves let's be honest right we
are all doing that and that's what i
learned like
i thought i was coming to country where
never needed that like first thing my
mom taught me
growing up in north korea was don't even
whisper
because the birds and mice could hear
you
and i thought okay now america is truly
the land of the free home of the brave
you can say anything you want and then
you have
freedom to change your mind and evolve
right
but the people now demand you to be the
perfect version they demand you to be
you cannot change your mind and then
what is the meaning of life you cannot
grow
right you should be feel safe to talk
about anything and then later okay
i was wrong but now if you do that you
gotta like get penalized for it
i mean censorship is a funny thing
because you probably should not say dumb
things
you should try to say things you want to
say in the most eloquent the most
effective way you can so i mean that's
what editing is
right yeah so there's some level of like
being careful with what you say not
because you're afraid
of some overarching kind of group
of bullies but you want to be the best
version of yourself when you express
stuff but there's some sense where in
the university setting
you can put that self-censorship like
level down more
and say stupid stuff right and explain
and play
because you should be forgiven for that
kind of uh
play especially when you're discussing
difficult aspects of human history
whether
that include racism that that include uh
atrocities
i'm still nevertheless sort of hopeful
but at the same time
i'm i'm surrounded by engineers yeah so
i don't get to interact with
people in humanities much and it seems
like there's
a good thing it's a good thing
yeah i don't know um well i do sort of
interact with psychologists but they
haven't touched on those kinds of topics
yet i still
sort of in defense of psychology i still
i wish i had more numbers yeah but i
still feel like
most psychology people don't partake in
this kind of stuff
either they're just doing excellent
research we're just highlighting
that's what america does well you're
kind of highlighting anecdotal
experiences
and uh making a big deal out of them
but that's good because like it's a
slippery slope if those if those things
start to overtake all of academia it
starts becoming a big problem even in
the engineering field so
we should be concerned but it is truly
tragic that somebody
who's exceptionally well read like you
whose
fire was stoked first with orwell
that fire should burn bright like this
should not be
you should be writing many books you
know what i mean like and
you'll be you talk to jordan you know
it's very possible
depending what you want to do with your
life that you'll be a future jordan
peterson
right so like that and columbia
should be a place that enriches
that your mind and the fact that it
didn't is is tragic
it's like i was there four years it
wasn't like i had
one class that was bad in one semester
yeah
that was the thing when dr p was asking
is there any one class
that had no sentiment of this this
virtue signaling politically right
yeah there was none yeah
entire course i think i took 126 credits
total
not even one class doesn't matter we
were talking about classic art and
that's the thing i literally thought
okay i pushed it last like the semester
the call like the art and music right
so i thought it's gonna be the least
politically correct class i can take
and then it begins with who has problem
with
calling this course the western
civilization muse of art and music
and it was raising their hands because
like why do you have to learning about
this better than mozart the bigots
and or the people like you know
everything ruined by white men
yeah and it's even music even these
paintings
and as i i didn't raise my hand
everyone's looking at me
how do you not have the problem with us
like you should hate us you're asian
you're so i think that's the thing
is i think the problems way deeper than
what people think
and it's it's so that's what i when i
learned
it's like it's not that safe in america
we can go complete to the south and
looking at even europe
that is like i used to be way more
optimistic like you know
that but now i actually see wow this
country can't go to south
and we might if u.s force land right
this is the only country
left to battle with the communist party
in china
we may lose the opportunity to be free
ever again as a humanity
wow so i mean that puts a lot of value
on having these kinds of conversations
it is i mean i'm troubled i'm troubled
by a lot of things but like censorship
on youtube for example
yeah it was very annoying to have to
listen to donald trump all the time
like just like create drama like the
news cycle was completely drowned out by
donald trump
but like banning him from twitter it was
like
that i that was uh that was scary for me
because
it's like that's a step towards the
direction where
you're going to like where's that take
us you're going to silence
people then it's like jordan peterson is
next that's why we need to promote
freedom of thinking
and speech right and one thing that i
love about dr peterson is
humans he's psychologists right he talks
about we
we we think by talking yeah that's why
when you go to therapy you talk and then
you
hear yourself and then you think and you
come up to the answer
it's so important for humans to talk so
we can think
so when they say you cannot talk means
you cannot think
and they don't know the consequences of
that and this is why
i promote i want the freedom of speech
even though it hurts
ridiculous you know sometimes it can it
can be dangerous
but the price the alternative is so bad
that we should take the you know make
this trade-off everything has a
trade-off in this world
and it comes with a sacrifice right so i
think that's uh
that's what i want to see in america but
it's unfortunately like the people like
you say
who decides what is hate speech what is
dangerous
that's what what i've been getting
scared because
everybody's imperfect yeah right how do
you want to give the power to
them and they're going to decide today
they might agree with me say okay your
speech is good
promo is good and then they might come
back next year so you're probably
bad what are you gonna do when that
happens to you
we have to almost like get ideas out and
then play with them
i think what's a really important
component of that is forgiving each
other for
like realizing the word different person
day by day and certainly years later
and i think some of that is both
cultural mechanisms of saying like we
forgive
each other for wrong ideas or not wrong
ideas but
for who we are the the full evolution of
the human being
for the steps we've taken on that
evolution and
also creating mechanisms that
allow you to um allow
us to forgive each other like for
example on a twitter is like horrible
with this because
one of the main viral ways that people
create drama on twitter is like
pulling up an old tweet that somebody
said right
and then saying oh this is the guy that
thinks that yeah
and but that's like the opposite of the
mechanisms we need
to forgive ourselves forgive each other
for the things we've said in the past
and um so part of that is the cultural
part of this is as
the technological
mechanisms
you